[Music]
[Music]
everyone my name is Jesse from the
BuzzFeed food team and say hang me
testing five famous celebrity guacamole
recipes to see which one is actually the
best today I'll be testing recipes for
Rachael Ray
I used to curry Alton Brown marcella bio
delete and Beyonce I measure all the
ingredients precisely the recipe stated
to level the playing field and I got
three my friends to try bok Moines and a
blind taste test I picked my winner but
I wanted to see what they thought so
game on Rachael Ray starts by mixing
diced red onions with lemon juice and
salt mixes it up and lets it sit for
about 10 minutes after that she cut some
pits - avocados and scoops the flesh out
on top of that onion mixture then add
some cilantro jalapeno and garlic and
mashes it all together but here's where
things get crazy next she adds even more
lemon juice diced apples and pureed
Chipotle in adobo then mix that all up
and seasons in to finish it she transfer
some into a bowl and tops it liberally
and entirely with toasted almonds and
even more apples we got almonds on the
guacamole that's not a thing okay okay
very chunky if I could think of like
Hawaiian guacamole this is what I think
I'd be getting guacamole usually has big
texture problems so I don't mind the
little bit of crunch from the almonds
almonds are good they kind of break up
the fruitiness and make it a little more
savory I'm kind of freaking out about
this because I don't know what to make
of it but I do like it
I don't love it I like it it's different
but if we go around not liking things
that are different from us come on man
America wake up Ayesha curry starts by
scooping the meat out of a single
avocado and placing it into a bowl she
called him me not me so don't add me in
the comments for this one she then adds
dice shouts hot sauce
chunky garlic paste lime juice salt and
pepper then just mash that all up with
the fork and that's it for this one
looks like this was a project between a
mom and a child this is all they could
achieve if something slaps me across the
my taste buds I'm gonna be angry because
it is so unassuming looking this is
definitely yeah like a bar quality
nothing special it's fine that's very
good you know it's not it's not spicy
but it's very creamy just your basic
Wacha male but it's good I like this one
up next is Alton Brown he starts with
three whole avocados cuts him in half
takes the pit out and scoops the flesh
into a ball to that he has lime juice
toss it all together and strains out the
extra juice into a tiny bowl because
you'll use this later next he adds
cayenne and cumin and mashed it all
together a potato masher to give it a
nice creamy texture he adds it garlic
onions jalapeno cilantro tomatoes and
the reserve lime juice and mix that all
together and that's it for this one
super classic this looks like a classy
welcome only the callers here say be by
making this looks like the type of block
that you got when you order at a
restaurant it's not very guacamole ie
there's an issue here there is a lack of
flavor it almost doesn't taste like
avocado or like vegetables it tastes
like tacos there's not enough seasoning
here not enough salt the basic of all
whack I'll say I don't like this one it
presents itself in a way where it looks
like it's gonna be the ultimate
guacamole and then it isn't well up next
is Food Network's personality Marcela V
just because I don't want to butcher her
last name with her sweet and spicy
guacamole she starts by cutting open
five avocados pits them and roughly mash
them all together fork to give it a nice
texture to that she adds diced mango red
pepper flakes a generous amount of salt
and a ton of lime juice and mix that all
together she places it into a bowl and
tops it with chili oil to add a pop of
heat it looks beautiful it's attractive
this looks like it's gonna be spicy
there's a big chunk of an orange fruit
really thrown me for a loop here
oh I lost sense of time where am I
what is that it tastes like Chinese food
oil tastes almost like Asian infused
this one is the most interesting by far
and it's good I mean to it unless is the
queen bee herself with a super
traditional recipe for guac she starts
by peeling two avocados and smash them
together with the spoon to smooth it all
out next she adds lime juice
tomato diced onion salt pepper and
garlic and mix that all together until
it's all incorporated transfer it to a
ball and that's it there goes our
another one that looks like it's about
to be a classic experience picturesque
little tomatoes in there this is what
you'll have at a Mexican restaurant just
have the right amount of seasoning the
right amount of tomatoes onions this is
almost like the closest to just like
guacamole okay by the books it seems
pretty straightforward the consistency
is really nice there's some texture too
it's not too chunky really good which
celebrity is the best clock of my recipe
let's find out my favorite out of all
these five recipes was number four a
beautiful reinvention of a classic
recipe done the freakin right way you
got sweet you get salty you get
everything are you serious Marcela
that is awesome my favorite was number
five it was just like your typical
guacamole but it was very good like a
good texture still creamy there was
something to like bite into with the
onions on the tomatoes and I could eat
that any day Oh got out flu IVs and one
lucky girl eating that all the time if I
had to pick a favor cuacamole today it
is without question guacamole number
four with the oil and the mangos in
there I was blown away it's good
guacamole I don't know who that is but
my theoretical hat is off to you there
you have it
Marcel that bio believe has the best
guacamole
which celebrity recipes should we try
next hit us up in the comments below
[Music]
maybe even better than classic recipe